[Musique]
salut à tous le 26 mai 2018
c'est à dire aujourd'hui pour ce qui
regarde cette vidéo le jour de sa
publication
une fois n'est pas coutume syndicats
partis et associations de gauche tentent
l'impossible s'unir dans la rue pour
contester la politique d' emmanuel
macron s'entredéchirer pour savoir qui
dirige la contestation ou qui est
légitime pour mobiliser habituellement
ce genre de mobilisation suscite des
tensions en france c'est historique
syndicats et partis de gauche ont du mal
à s'entendre quand il s'agit de savoir
qui doit porter la parole populaire
en général les syndicats considèrent que
toute contestation portant sur le monde
du travail leur revient de droit
alors pourquoi ce conflit récurrent
entre politiques et syndicales pour le
comprendre
faisons un peu d'histoire cette défiance
réciproque remonte à la création des
partis et syndicats dans la seconde
moitié du 19e siècle la révolution
industrielle chamboule alors les pays
d'europe de l'ouest
angleterre france et allemagne en tête
où apparaît la classe ouvrière qui vit
dans une misère noire
un courant va naître voulant transformer
la société dans un souci d'égalité le
socialisme ce socialisme qui est alors
une idée vague va s'orienter dans deux
directions
ceux qui veulent transformer la société
par les revendications sociales et vont
créer les syndicats et ceux qui croient
à la lutte politique qui vont créer des
partis au départ la frontière entre les
deux types d'organisation n'est pas très
clair on parlait alors de mouvement
ouvrier
l'histoire des relations entre parti
socialiste et syndicats varie d'un pays
à l'autre
en france le mouvement ouvrier est
traversé de multiples courants plus ou
moins radicaux plus ou moins sectaires
il y a les alémany sts très
révolutionnaire mais peu doctrinaux pro
syndicat des guesdistes les premiers à
introduire le marxisme en france pour
qui le parti doit diriger le syndicat et
il y aussi les socialiste réformiste
comme jaurès qui est pro parti mais qui
veut une autonomie du syndicat et puis
il faut ajouter des anarchistes
antiparlementaire et révolutionnaire qui
tolèrent mal les parties le socialisme
syndicale est aussi éclaté que le
socialisme deux parties il est constitué
de syndicats locaux aussi appelé bourse
du travail et le syndicat de branche
indépendant il n'y a pas de
confédération pour unifier le tout
jusqu'en 1895 où une grande partie de
ces petits syndicats se réunissent et
donne naissance à la cgt et
du travail les rejoignant en 1902 la cgt
est alors traversé par tous les courants
du socialisme mais c'est le syndicalisme
révolutionnaire expression des
anarchistes dans le syndicat qui domine
les socialistes deux parties vont
signifier en 1905 dans la sf bio mais
n'ont pas de doctrine cohérente dans les
années 1900 en 1905
l'église se veulent toujours transformé
le syndicat en courroie de transmission
pour le parti la cgt est donc la proie
de luttes intestines et son congrès de
1906 qui se tient à amiens va trancher
la question des relations syndicats
partis en les formalisant dans un court
texte appelait charte d'amiens
cette charte proclame l'indépendance du
syndicat par rapport au parti et a été
adopté grâce à l'alliance entre
socialiste réformiste et anarchiste qui
tous deux veulent faire échec au visage
et d'ist au delà de son rôle
conjoncturel
la charte est fondatrice d'une forme de
syndicalisme à la française
reconnaissance de la lutte des classes
volonté d'abolition du capitalisme mythe
de la grève générale révolutionnaire
elle aura une grande postérité même si
le volet révolutionnaire est depuis
longtemps remisé au placard par exemple
c'est au nom du respect de cette charte
a été créé force ouvrière en 1947 alors
que la cgt tombée aux mains des
communistes staliniens qui en feront un
jouet du pcf
paradoxalement la charte est aussi
toujours mentionnée dans les statuts de
la cgt
et aujourd'hui encore dès que les
relations deviennent tendues entre
partis et syndicats pas mal de ces
derniers citent la charte et c'est pour
ça que jean luc mélenchon lui aimerait
bien l'avoir remisé au placard comme il
l'a clairement dit après l'échec de sa
propre tentative de mobilisation en
septembre 2010 est ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que la charte est une
conséquence indirecte très déplaisantes
elle crée une prédominance des syndicats
qui présente toute mobilisation portant
sur le monde du travail donc une grande
partie des questions sociales les
parties devant se contenter de mobiliser
sur les questions morales ou sociétales
et devant rester cantonné à l'action
symbolique et parlementaires ce qui de
fait vide un peu les partis de gauche
d'une partie de leurs fonctions le
socialisme qu'il peut
lisez sur le social c'est embêtant et le
plus paradoxal c'est que les syndicats
qui ont mal vécu les tentatives de
mobilisation populaire de mélenchon ne
se gêne pas pour aller sur le terrain
politique par exemple sur les questions
écologiques ou sur les questions
d'égalité des sexes
si en france les relations sont
compliquées dans d'autres pays
les choses sont beaucoup plus simples en
fait historiquement vous avez trois
modèles de rapports partis syndicats
les modèles français anglais et allemand
en angleterre ce sont les syndicats qui
se sont développées en premier et qui
ont créé le parti socialiste pour porter
leurs aspirations au parlement ce n'est
pas pour rien qu'on parle de parti
travailliste est aujourd'hui encore les
syndicats vote pour l'élection du
dirigeant du parti ce qui explique qu
actuellement jérémy torby n'en soit le
chef alors qu'il fait partie de l'ailé
gauche les syndiqués sont plus à gauche
que les membres des partis en allemagne
c'est l'inversé ce sont les partis
socialistes qui ont créé les syndicats
qui leur servent de prolongement
populaire on remarquera que dans les
deux cas ces pays ont eu un socialisme
moins contestataire qu'en france mais
que les acquis sociaux ont été plus
précoce peut-être que quand les
syndicats et les partis ne se tire pas
dans les pattes les causes qu'ils
défendent avance mieux mais il faut bien
le dire le socialisme français est aussi
tributaire de l'histoire il a subi
d'importantes répression comme celle qui
a suivi l'insurrection de la commune de
paris
vingt mille morts et des milliers de
déportés en nouvelle calédonie après ça
on comprend que les socialistes français
ne soit pas très optimiste vis-à-vis de
l'option politique au sein de la
république bourgeoise et que nombre
d'entre eux et favoriser l'action
syndicale
résultat le socialisme français a raté
l'unité organique au 19e siècle et il ya
peu de chances que les relations entre
syndicats et partis s'améliore l'unité
impliquant la subordination de l'une des
deux composantes à l'autre on verra bien
les suites de la marée populaire du 26
mai mais à mon avis ce n'est qu'un
épiphénomène qui ne durera pas
l'indépendance syndicale et la charte
d'amiens serviront à justifier les
ruptures quoi qu'il en soit j'espère que
cette vidéo vous aura apporté quelques
éléments de compréhension sur ce sujet
si c'est le cas et bien n'hésitez pas à
la partager
et quant à moi il ne me reste plus qu'à
vous dire à la prochaine
[Musique]